[Musique]
comme benneteau un chat sur trois vit en
appartement alors le ch a peut-être eu
en appartement à condition d'observer
certaines règles pour son bien-être
[Musique]
d'abord la gamme elle doit être vraiment
dans un endroit calme comme ici par
exemple au sol ou en hauteur en hauteur
s'il ya un chien comme le cas de
benneteau le chat est un grignoteurs il
a besoin d'une quinzaine de mini repas
dans la journée c'est son régime
alimentaire puisque dans la nature ils
mangent des souris et quand on lui donne
des croquettes comme ça dans une gamelle
il a tendance à trop à manger donc dans
ces cas là il vaut mieux mettre ses
croquettes soit dans des gamelles anti
glouton où il va jouer à aller chasser
ses croquettes soit encore dans des
haltères où des boules qu'il doit faire
rouler pour pouvoir avoir quelques cons
tête qui tourne
ça stimule son comportement de chasse
qui est innée et qui a un besoin profond
en lui et en même temps ça lui permet de
s'alimenter
[Musique]
ce conseil de multiplier les points
d'alimentation pour le chat dans la
maison c'est mieux pour lui c'est mieux
pour son bien-être
en complément je vous conseille de lui
donner des aliments umih matin et soir
c'est à dire des sachets des boîtes ou
des repas que vous lui confectionner ce
sont des aliments qui apportent beaucoup
d'eau et surtout qui rassasient le chat
est évident qu'ils mangent trop et ne
grossisse ou concernant sa boisson sa
gamelle d'eau est ici c'est très bien
puisqu'on est dans un coin elle doit
être fraîche renouveler une à deux fois
par jour et dans un endroit calme non
pas 100 concernant le nombre de litière
la reine le sait une litière par chaque
plus une c'est-à-dire de litière pour un
chat et 3 litière s'il ya deux chats
dans l'appartement
là je vois qu'il ya une porte et ça je
déconseille les portes sur les litières
fermé tout simplement parce que ça fait
milieu de culture
il ya beaucoup d'odeur et le char chine
après à venir dans la litière
[Musique]
on
le plus important c'est qu'il ne soit
pas perturbée quand il y va pour qu'il
n'ait pas de tendance à aller faire
autre part donc à distance du lave-linge
du lave vaisselle et à distance aussi de
la gamelle puisque le chat n'aime pas
manger dans ses toilettes
pour le bien-être et leur peau du chat
il y à des accessoires qui sont
indispensables comme par exemple les
grilles foire alors les grilles foire
permet de bien sûr au chat de cris fait
c'est un besoin physiologique c'est un
plaisir et c'est une méthode aussi pour
lui de marquer son territoire
il a besoin de signifier à ses
congénères
là où il demeure son territoire et
surtout les endroits où il se repose
pour ne pas être dérangé il faut minimum
de griffoir par chat
[Musique]
en suisse est un animal qui vit en
hauteur en trois dimensions et c'est
important de lui réserver des zones de
refuge en hauteur sur un arbre à chat à
un mac des couffins sur une étagère par
exemple il ne faut pas lui interdire
d'aller sur les meubles pour disposer un
arbre à chat il vaut mieux le maître
soit à côté d'une source de chaleur
comme un radiateur parce que les chats
adorent la chaleur soit et ça c'est
encore le mieux près d'une fenêtre
tout simplement parce que ça sera un
poste d'observation pour le chat il va
passer des heures à regarder à
l'extérieur les oiseaux tout ce qui se
passe tout ces stimulations visuelles
qui sont très importantes pour son
psychisme
le chat est d'abord un grimpeur né il a
besoin de prendre de la hauteur beaucoup
plus qu'un chien par exemple parce que
la hauteur lui permet non seulement de
se mettre à l'abri de s'isoler mais ça
lui permet aussi d'observer son
environnement pour voir s'il y à
d'éventuelles proies ou aussi des
concurrents qui viennent sur son
territoire
[Musique]
j'ai des cannes à pêche des plumeaux les
petites balles que l'on sait rouler au
sol des petits jouets avec de l'herbe à
chat de dans des petits jouets avec des
plumes qui ressemble à un petit oiseau
[Musique]
le jeu est en fait un simulacre de
chasse et comme les félins sauvages le
chat a besoin de chasser bien entendu
donc il va falloir jouer avec lui lui
donner des jouets le principal c'est
varier les plaisirs c'est à dire de lui
sortir tous les deux jours de nouveau
joué puisque le chat se lasse très vite
de son jouet n'est ce pas bientôt la
première cause d'accident ménagers chez
le chat d'appartement
c'est la chute accidentelle d'une
fenêtre ou d'un balcon
c'est pour ça qu'il faut les sécuriser
soit avec un grillage soit avec un filet
pour éviter qu'ils le chute
il faut faire très attention à prendre
un chat qui a toujours vécu en
appartement qui n'a pas eu accès à
l'extérieur pour qu'ils puissent bien
s'acclimater
dans son nouvel appartement un chat
d'appartement peut avoir un certain mal
être parce qu'il s'ennuie ou parce qu'il
est anxieux si un chat passe ses
journées à dormir s'il ne s'intéresse
pas à son environnement s'il ne joue
plus s'ils mangent beaucoup ou pas
beaucoup s'il se lèchent beaucoup aussi
ou s'il devient aussi agressif tous ces
comportements veulent dire qu'il a un
mal être et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
d'abord aller voir un vétérinaire pour
savoir ce qui se passe est aussi peut
être réaménagé l'environnement échanger
vos interactions avec lui
faites attention vous êtes très
important dans la vie d'un chat les jeux
que vous aurez avec lui les câlins
quotidien votre présence sur votre amour
font aussi le bonheur du chat
d'appartement et c'est très important
[Musique]